hey folks
this is a test of the audio video system
that is associated with the dark horse
podcast can you at least
establish for us that there is audio and
there is video
second level are the two things in sync
third level can you hear me at a
pleasant amplitude
that is not driving you crazy should you
be wearing headphones
these are the details we need to know
from you as we hurdle
towards the 44th dark horse podcast
live stream in just a few minutes
we have evidence everything is working
we will see you in a few minutes
ciao
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream
our 44th am i correct about that number
you are correct
all right um up front today we have to
talk about a couple
of caveats and anomalies one
is as we will talk more about later in
the broadcast
we are facing an incredible inundation
of smoke and if you hear us
coughing and gagging during the podcast
that is what is taking place hopefully
there won't be any gagging
well all right we'll try to resist
gagging but nonetheless it is uh people
call us now they you know know we live
in portland and they ask well what's it
like how are you doing and
the only analogy i have come up with is
that it is something
like living inside of a bong a bong a
bong
i mean i've never lived in a bong no you
haven't this
in portland it looks like what it must
look like from inside of a bong
looking out and frankly just as
unpleasant unpleasant and no fun
whatsoever so it's you know
maybe water pipe would be a better way
to say it but anyway it's not
it's not very nice out and i will um i
will say it's uh
it's awfully after so much covet
lockdown
the um the loophole in covid was of
course
outdoors and now going outdoors is
hazardous to your health and so
i must say i'm feeling more locked down
than i have uh maybe ever
no abs absolutely it's even driving the
animals crazy at this point
yep all right the other uh caveat that i
have to mention
is you may notice some video glitches
during this stream
and i raise it because we are in the
following bizarre situation
so we have a little bit of a complicated
podcast set up here
we started noticing glitches on uh on
our camera
and we went about troubleshooting and we
went through
at first we have three cameras that are
identical they all showed the same
glitching we substituted in another
camera it showed the glitching
we have swapped out the computer every
other piece of hardware we have run
everything off of batteries to see that
it is not our wall power causing the
problem it happens when we are not
connected to the internet
so in short we have eliminated every
possible cause of the glitching we have
falsified
every hypothesis save one
may i mention uh one of your
interventions uran's saks interventions
or should i not
no you may yeah you you literally built
tin foil hats for the cameras
we did wrap the cameras in tin foil so
this is the problem is the one remaining
hypothesis
that could possibly explain the
glitching of all of our cameras and we
are now by the way this is our fifth
camera that you are
you are seeing through at the moment and
it is also glitching though slightly
less than the others
um the only hypothesis left standing is
interference from something external
now oddly which could be thwarted by
uh aluminum foil could be and in fact we
saw some effect
if we put the aluminum foil but it's not
complete we can't protect any of the
cameras completely by wrapping them in
foil at least by any technique that we
have used
now if we take the cameras out of this
room they stop doing it
so i don't say they start functioning
again they start functioning normally
and we can't reproduce the problem
so i don't know what to make of this
right it it
certainly um triggers my tinfoil
hat side because you falsify every
hypothesis
and what are you left with is you know
either so it's at least convenient that
it triggers it both literally and
metaphorically so that you don't have to
keep track of the two narratives
right well exactly it's very it is uh
narratively convenient in that
uh in its own way in a way that
conspiracy theorizing rarely is but
exactly um yeah so i don't know i don't
know what to make of this maybe somebody
out there in our audience will have i've
been
searching for the answer that would
connect
the smoke or the fires
you know in some ways the smoke
interrupting cell signals so that
they've
turned up the amplitude on them in order
to compensate in a way that might be
intruding
but frankly we're not all that close to
a cell tower
you know and why would the problems uh
not persist when you just moved the
cameras
to another two rooms over or something
right so um this is a
it's a head scratcher but anyway if you
see color bars show up
uh we are aware of the problem um but
having falsified every hypothesis we
we got nothing yeah yeah
all right so we're gonna talk about fire
and sex today
fire and sex yeah but not at the same
time not but in that order
yes all right i believe so fair enough
yeah
uh so many many people will know
that we are in portland oregon and
portland oregon uh is experiencing
as all of oregon in fact all of the west
coast is experiencing
uh extraordinary wildfire situations um
portland itself does not have any active
evacuation orders although um the
evacuation orders are
are close um to to most people in
portland at this point including us
and apparently the air quality in our
city right now is the worst in the world
and has been for about 48 hours and it
certainly feels that way when you walk
outside of course i've never been to
delhi or beijing or um you know but i it
it's it's far worse than what i remember
los angeles being like in the 70s when
we grew up when the sky was
reliably yellow with smog right with
particulate matter that was suspended
in the air and uh this is this is far
far far worse so um i thought we'd talk
a bit about what fire is what humans
history with fire is
uh including on the west coast and
elsewhere um
and you know what what might be causing
these fires and what the effects might
be
so uh at first i i feel a little bit
like
defending portland against this uh claim
that it has the worst
air quality on earth and i must say i'm
a little skeptical of this because i'm
not even sure that what we've got here
qualifies as air at this point
i think it's too solid right yeah right
so
you know it's it's it's air in the same
way that styrofoam is air
that's an extraordinary defense well
it's the best i could come up with
yeah um so let's just start uh with
just a paragraph from the draft of uh
the book that we're writing
um which in which we talk about fire a
little bit
um in service of talking about the human
innovation that is cooking specifically
but
um fire is is um early and
critical in every human evolution story
so
over a million and a half years ago our
ancestors were already controlling fire
fire brings many advantages of course it
provides warmth and light
a warning of protection against
dangerous animals and a beacon to
friends
a little later on in our relationship
with controlled fire we began to use it
to boil water and make it potable
to eradicate pests to dry our clothes to
temper metal with which to make tools
with fire we can see each other and our
work at night and we may gather around
it telling stories or making music
there are no known human cultures
without fire although early reports from
anthropologists missionaries and
explorers often made claims to the
contrary
none other than darwin suggests that the
art of making fire was quote
probably the greatest discovery
accepting language ever made by men
so um that that goes into our deep
history
um i thought we might also
why is this not working it's fun um zach
can you show
this um my screen here
um and so this is this is a figure from
a book
called isle of fire the political
ecology of landscape burning in
madagascar by christian call
so regular viewers and listeners will
know that i did my
graduate research in madagascar and
brett and i both spent a fair bit of
time there i've actually written a book
about my
experiences there and this is a book
that
proved useful though not directly
relevant obviously to my exploration of
the sex lives of poison frags which is
more of what i was focused on but
madagascar being the fourth largest
island in the world
bigger than california off the east
coast of africa
and there is a long history of the use
of fire
both for landscape modification and for
protest
by people among most of the 13 or 14
tribes of madagascar
so this this book
early on discusses some of the causes or
goals of fire
um and some of the effects and because
many of these
are relevant in discussion of what's
happening in the american west right now
i thought i'd go through just a couple
of these of course there are um
non-human causes like lightning and
other sources
and then a whole lot of of things that
you might do
um here human-caused purposeful
uh on on this figure that are
constructive
maintaining pasture preparing crops
as in the traditional method in many
tropical
tropical regions of agriculture called
sweden or
often called slash and burn which is
actually an effective mode
of agriculture at low population
densities but it becomes ineffective at
high population densities and that's one
of the things that
we will talk about here i think
management of pests and
and cleaning up of detritus all of these
things are
understood to be constructive purposeful
um reasons to set fires and of course
there are destructive reasons as well
and in this figure christian call says
revenge or personal gain
right so the uh the
odd sociopath or psychopath or um simply
very angry person or protest and of
course it can be hard sometimes to tell
the difference between those two things
and then finally just in terms of
categories um human-caused accidental
fires
exist where a campfire gets away from
you cigarette butts get thrown out of
windows
somebody's gender is a bit more
explosive than one imagines
is foreign strategy on here uh
in other words denying your enemy a
resource or corralling your enemy to
some place where you have an advantage
my guess is that that's gonna fit under
other
under control constructive um you know
so so depending on how you view it you
know what side of the interaction you're
on you might view is destructive
and therefore it's revenge or personal
gain or you know statewide gain
um or um other under constructive so you
know successful
military strategy yeah um
and uh you know maybe maybe maybe that's
enough to start uh for those of you just
uh just listening to this we have not
described the full
the full figure but um
but definitely some of it so um
you know there's a lot to say but i
think probably um beginning a
conversation as opposed to me just
you know going on and on about the
various things that are true
about fire throughout human history but
maybe maybe one more thing first before
we start talking
um fire has been a feature of the
american west for as long as we have
records
uh which given that we can go back uh
and look at pollen cores from you know
several hundred thousand years um that's
a long time
um also the west is not just one place
there are at least
four distinct regions uh the pacific
northwest where we are now
um the uh the coastal west
farther south the inland
west and then the inland southwest
really have different
different species compositions different
fire regimes different seasonality with
regard to
when it's dry when it's not how cold it
gets how hot it gets all of these things
but at least several
several good pieces of research and
there's certainly several a lot of bad
research as well
but significantly significant amounts of
good research
find for instance that at least since
1400
bad fire years have been consistently
associated with summer drought
the drought years and this you know this
seems obvious when you say it but
actually by looking at um basically fire
scars and trees from a database across
350 sites in the american west
they find that fires are reliably
predicted
by drought earlier in the summer um not
as reliably predicted by temperature
in some parts of the west that's true
but unless actually the pacific
northwest
um and uh that there have of course been
mega droughts in the american west
before we are probably in the middle of
one now
or or getting into one um this
this one appears to be the worst in the
last
since uh well i don't have it written
down maybe since the 1500s i think
and most of the models uh that i
see and you know whenever we say models
i want to put an asterisk there and say
okay this is this is a model
this we have now um gone outside the
realm of the directly
measurable um suggests that 30 to 50
of the explanation for increasing
drought is due to climate change
and so that's not 100 that's not even
close to 100 but there is certainly
an explanatory component here of
increasing fires in the american west
um that has to do with increasing number
of droughts and the droughts seem to be
um have a 30 to 50 percent roughly
um explanation due to climate
anthropogenic climate change
so uh there are about a dozen things in
there i want to respond to of course
one is interesting that it is summer
drought and not winter drought
um that is predictive it could be either
and so the fact that one of these is
more
um is contributing more strongly is
interesting
and there it's more complicated right
that there is some stuff around snow
reduced snowpack
in the california in california not so
much up here in the pacific northwest
but in california reduced snowpack which
is going to be about winter drought
uh can increase the risk of of summer
fires of summer and fall fires
right and so um you know some
effect on agriculture for example is
typically going to be about winter
drought
because it's about snowpack which fill
refills
uh aquifers and reservoirs and things
like that which is a very different
phenomenon
than we're talking about here um so you
know
so drought isn't one thing it's at least
two things and um they will both have a
contributory um capacity so just to be
clear you're saying the two things in
this case and i think it's more
are just um the seasonality of the
drought right winter drought versus
summer job right you can imagine
having a you know a normal summer
and a dry winter and that would affect
agriculture but it
might not affect fires etc so
anyway there's that i also wanted to
just point out this story i don't know
where you're going but i have a feeling
that this story is one that is just
going to be haunted throughout by
um equilibria and their disruption
exactly
and so i wanted to say you mentioned
that sweden agriculture the burning
of an area which most people are
familiar with as slash and burn slash
and burn agriculture
is very effective at low density
why now it's effective at low density
because
fire takes nutrients that are stored in
above ground plant matter and it returns
some of them to the soil as ash
effectively
and it liberates some of them into the
atmosphere where they no longer
contribute to the growing of plants so
you can grow crops there with the burst
of nutrients
that you release with the fire but a lot
less than the biomass that once stood
so effectively in a tropical situation
where you don't have a big
buildup of resources you have to keep
moving
right exactly which is why low
population density is a limiting
factor on that one and i mean and
additional additional reasons that
sweden works at low population densities
is that um
it's going to work only at low at low
spatial scale
because a fire that's out of control
it's going to release almost all of its
nutrients into the atmosphere which is
what we're seeing here right now and
it's
it's you know making it very hard to
breathe for a lot of people and a lot of
other organisms as well
whereas a low slow burn allows that
the mold ring to go back into into the
ground basically and so what you end up
with in these sweden plots
are they're small they tend to be
surrounded on at least three sides by
intact forest
uh which means that they can then be
repopulated once you grow on them for
four six
eight years until you've used the
nutrients that you'd released from the
slow
low burn and then you let the forest
grow back in at which point you know you
cycle through and if you come back to
that original plot 20 years from now
but that means that you've got i'm just
making up numbers here but you know 19
out of 20 of your plots in any given
moment
are not actively under agriculture and
you can't do that in any kind of
intensive agricultural regime
it's crop rotation on a very different
time scale and
um you know before you ever label it as
such
um one more thing that you mentioned um
that won't be obvious to most people is
that
unlike in for instance the central
valley of california or
um the great plains and um sort of upper
midwest
of um of the united states like iowa and
such
um that are that are that have been such
rich fertile croplands
uh where the the nutrients really do
live in the soil
in the lowland wet tropics the nutrients
live in the biomass
excuse me not in the soil and so what
you're doing what you have to basically
clue just such a system if you're trying
to do agriculture in these very poor
tropical soils
to get the nutrients that are above
ground into the soil right so actually
it takes a fair amount of sophistication
the forest that grows back after you
have done sweden agriculture
in the tropics is not the same forest so
this is another one of these lessons is
that you're actively
taking over the management of an
ecosystem and so even things that look
like virgin forests like the amazon it
turns out
are tremendously affected by you know
many thousands of years
of intensive agriculture the evidence of
which has mostly been buried so
at first people didn't you know the west
did not understand that it had taken
place at all
right and that's i mean that's a huge
part of this story that you know where
where is wild nature you know to to what
degree does anyone
and and we as people who desire to spend
as much time
in as untrammeled nature as possible we
have to recognize that actually almost
everywhere on the planet at this point
has been managed by humans
at some point to some degree and it's
harder and harder to do
the greater population density gets yeah
um
and there's this i mean i guess we'll
get back to it but the
naivete at the point that you you know
at the point that europeans show up in
the new world and
you know for one thing many of the
populations that were in the new world
that is the americas when europeans
showed up were hunter-gatherers not all
of them
there were large civilizations here but
nonetheless hunter-gatherer populations
are less troubled
by the burning of a particular piece of
habitat because they're not as wedded to
it
right so at the point that you you know
take a settlement
approach then you view fire as an enemy
and you your temptation is to suppress
it but the problem is this interrupts a
different equilibrium
right yes which i don't know if you
wanna you probably have
a lot to say on the subject but the
equilibrium in question
is the accumulation of fuel so there's
some
tendency as more and more fuel that is
to say
dead wood and other above ground dead
biomass
is accumulating there's a higher risk
that any given spark like from lightning
will trigger a fire and then the point
is the amount of fuel
goes to a very low level an unusually
low level at which point fire becomes
much less likely to happen again
and so anyway there's a natural
equilibrium that is chaotic
but nonetheless maintained by the fact
that there's a certain amount of
ignition from things like lightning and
a tendency to burn off the fuel
and so as soon as a and a single
giant fire in most of the american west
that happens
as a result of those things are we still
live zach
okay yep um
it's apparently a single large fire is
recovered from
relatively quickly um from uh the
plant and animal and fungus perspective
uh and and bacteria and everything but
get
two or three in rapid succession and
it's it's both
harder for the ecosystems be they forest
or
savannah or prairie or whatever it is
some of which of course were created by
human management in the past
um it's harder for them to grow back in
part because
a second fire coming rapidly on the
heels of a first
say one or two years later has all of
that now fallen wood
to burn so just like we were talking
about with regard to sweden agriculture
you know successful
slash and burn agriculture leaves a lot
of sort of coal
sitting on the surface that can be dug
in right so the equivalent of
the of the wood that is partially burned
that is that is sitting on the surface
the next fire comes through well that
fire is going to catch more
quickly and burn hotter and destroy even
some of those
plants that actually need fire to for
instance set seed in the first place
so you have two things that work this
way you have
um the positive feedback that comes from
the initial fire freeing up more
fuel basically rendering wood more
likely to burn
and the other thing is that the
accumulation of the fuel in the first
place that comes from intensive fire
suppression
results in much higher f hotter fires in
the first place yes and because the
fires are
hotter in the first place they tend to
kill things that otherwise are adapted
to withstand them so
you know things like sequoias are so
long-lasting that of course they have to
live through fires and you'll see the
evidence that a given tree
you know has been burned multiple times
and it survives its part and in fact
you know the uh the germination of seeds
of many species actually require fire so
at the point that you naively think fire
bad and you start suppressing it
you're setting in motion the things that
make fire much rarer and
much worse exactly and um
you know there's i mean there's so many
places to go here fire is
you know one of the biggest topics that
that we could talk about right and
you know one of the things we don't have
this problem up here in the pacific
northwest but in california
eucalyptus has been introduced from
australia
and of course is you know thrives with
fire and so when
fires happen with eucalyptus around
those fires tend to get extraordinarily
hot
and almost the only organism who wins in
that situation is the eucalyptus itself
so um what you what you just said though
uh reminds me of this there's a
hypothesis that was first proposed in
1991
that is loosely framed as pyrodiversity
increases biodiversity
and that was from a paper that i can't
get access to it was conference
proceedings but a more recent paper
bowman at all 2016
summarizes the argument uh this way let
me just let me just share this here
uh this is a 2016 summary of martin and
sapsis's 1991
hypothesis that pyrodiversity increases
biodiversity
human manipulation of landscape fires
whether deliberate or accidental is a
powerful ecological force that can
influence the conservation of
biodiversity in the provision of
ecosystem services
and positively or negatively affect the
risk of economically disruptive fires
nonetheless there remains substantial
discussion and disagreement among fire
managers ecologists and conservation
biologists over how best to achieve
ecologically and economically
sustainable fire management
this debate reflects the myriad
competing objectives of fire management
and the social values that influence
them
etc martin and sapps has first
introduced the term pyrodiversity in
their exploration of the biodiversity
consequences of the transition from
native american fire management
to 20th century fire suppression by
government agencies
they characterized this transition as a
shift from a pattern of anthropogenic
burning that created and maintained
fine-grained habitat mosaics to one that
produced fire induced heterogeneity in
the landscape
this shift was driven by changes in the
spatial extent small to large
frequency frequent to infrequent
seasonality
an increase in summer just like you said
and severity
low to high of fires martin and sapsis
suggested these changes reduced the pyro
diversity with accompanying losses of
biodiversity
and recommended the implementation of
heterogeneous fire regimes
tailored to suit particular environments
and taxi to conserve biodiversity
now this is a hypothesis that is you
can't experimentally test it because
that would be immoral at best
um but you can you can go back and look
at um at
data on fires um that have been managed
in the sort of the
more standard 20th century let's you
know let's suppress fires and let them
happen on rare occasions in one
particular way
uh versus looking at some of these more
heterogeneous techniques
that were used um in earlier times and
it does seem that pyro diversity does
increase biodiversity
but can it be done
in a modern and 21st century environment
where there are economic forces that are
different and population density
is higher and people have different
considerations about what it is
they're trying to maximize well um first
of all i mean it seems
almost certain that this hypothesis will
turn out to be true i will i'll be a
stickler and i will say i don't think
it's fair to say you can't do the
experiment a
it's not clear to me in the case that
you
um you don't know the answer that you
can't effectively
say well you can test it but you're
that's not doing an experiment
that's my distinction you're fine if
we're going to be a semantic sticklers
that's my distinction i'm going to
stickle right back because
my point would be actually you can run
the experiment you can say as long as we
don't know
which of these fire suppression regimes
is uh better for us
it actually is moral to deploy them in
such a way that we can at least detect
the difference
um so i think it is fair to do that
one has to do it responsibly but the
other thing is in the case that you
can't do it because it's
declared immoral right let's say that
some fire suppression
regime is clearly inferior then it would
be
immoral to deploy it over any large
landscape but
then you have the natural experiment of
where it was done before people knew so
i don't
the reason i'm stickling is that it is
an experiment but it's what we call a
natural experiment
like the galapagos is a natural
experiment rather than an intentional
laboratory or field and that wasn't just
an excuse to tell me you were sticking
back
no and only the biologists in our in our
audience are gonna
understand that stickling back is
basically it's like a declaration of war
it's a declaration of fish at least it
is it's a it's a very fishy declaration
of war
um all right so sorry now what's my
train of thought
um let's see well let me let me say a
couple more things and i'll bet you find
your train of thought again
um so some of the errors that we find in
in
thinking and you know i would say on
sort of both sides of the political
aisles
some some of these errors are on one
side some on the other um
more on the on the right side of the
political aisle we see
imaginings that the environment can just
be controlled it can be mastered
that all we have to do is figure out
what needs to be done and control mother
nature and be done with it
and this imagines that the environment
is static about over both
time and space um and that strategies
that will work at small scale will also
work at large scale
and you know all of all of the issues uh
that were mentioned in this original
martin and sepsis paper
that small and large are the same
frequent and infrequent fires will act
the same way
that uh decrease in the heterogeneity of
seasonality will act the same way as
having fires in both seasons
and severity won't change anything so
so you cannot you can cannot just come
in with a heavy hand
as a bunch of humans and control nature
it's not it's not going to work
um that said the
sort of the naive error in thinking that
tends to be more likely to come from the
left
is that if we just leave nature alone it
will heal itself and become its original
self
and the the reason that this is um i
think this is a less egregious error
but precisely because of what you raised
just a few minutes ago that actually
there's very little
truly wild land left and we would you
know i
i would like more land set aside for
national park
you know rather than national forest
like i would i would i would
like more of this land that actually can
be left to
to do what it's going to do but the idea
that um either uh the
the earth itself will find an
equilibrium that suits our temperaments
or that the people who lived here before
before us we're doing something that was
inherently peaceful and lovely and would
work at scale
um are both pretty naive so i would uh
introduce two concepts here one is
the the idea of walking into a complex
system
and managing it from the get-go as if
you understand what the forces are
um in play is folly to begin with
and so it's the hubris of the 20th
century really it's
it's the hubris of those who have
learned well the lessons of simple
systems and then attempt to apply them
to complex systems and so
the fact that complex systems are uh
relatively
newly well studied means that we are now
beginning to understand what we were
doing wrong but in some sense
it was chester chesterton's fence all
along and at the point that you walk
into a system that you know to be
complex
what you know is that your simple
interventions are going to have
cascading effects that you can't
anticipate
right and we should have seen this
coming all along
so anyway one thing is
instead of trying to return things to a
natural state which is effectively
impossible
not messing them up in the first place
is a way better deal
right so it's tough though because we've
pretty much messed them up at this point
we have and the problem the problem is i
mean a when you tell people
there are no wildlands truly wild lands
left
have the sense that what you're saying
is it's lost
rather than let me tell you a story the
amazon as we know it
is not natural right there was an amazon
there is an amazon they're two different
forests they've been radically altered
by
intensive human use however it's not
like the amazon
is not a fascinating and wild place it's
just not
in its original state and we can also
say you know because because you and i
have been lucky enough to be traveling
to lowland tropical rainforests for
decades at this point and only to the
amazon since
2013 i guess i was there briefly in the
brazilian amazon in
2003 but um
we've been going to the same place a
couple of times since 2013
and even since then um the last time we
were there was earlier this year
which we've noticed noted before is
impossible to imagine but we were there
in january of 2020 and the first time we
were there was in june of 2013.
and the amazon that we saw in june of
2013
was it's you know this glorious jungle
wild seeming incredibly biodiverse in
fact it's understood this particular
spot in the
ecuador and amazon is understood to be
the most biodiverse spot on earth
and a mere seven years later we are
already seeing um a decline in
biodiversity
and you know we we imagine um that
three of the three of the things that
are happening is an increase in
oil drilling and an increase in
the insecticides that are traveling down
river and killing off the insects which
are then affecting the insectivorous
birds which are then affecting the
organisms that eat the insecticides
and again to return to this the
widespread fires that have been allowed
to flourish in the brazilian amazon
especially since bolsonaro took office
um which are in part the result of the
development that he's encouraging
and you know basically once you build a
road um the
the wildness of a place is going to
quickly um decline
and you get this phenomenon which
there's still
quite a lot of wildlife in in yasuni
where we
where we go but there's an awful lot of
forest
on the way to that most diverse place on
earth
and the really terrifying thing is how
quickly
you can deplete a piece of forest of its
animals or at least its large animals
um and so you know to a casual observer
it looks like oh there's so much forest
and the point is no no some of this
forest
you know you could walk for quite a long
way and not encounter
any um large animal life no vertebrates
to speak of or not many anyway it'd be
some common birds but
not much else and the point is that
people
especially people armed with modern
tools
can deplete a piece of habitat very
quickly and so
this this thing that tropical biologists
know but have a hard time compelling
others of
is that the road is the death knell
right if you think well we're just going
to put you know it's one strip of forest
like relax
right it's one you know it's you know
how many meters wide is a road it's not
that big a deal it's like no no
you've just given access to all of these
expert hunters who now
have access to modern tools to all of
this forest that would have been
uh very difficult to access before and
it just it empties them
and it's stunning in part i mean we're
far afield from talking about fire
directly here but it's
the what what was obvious to us in
tipputini in
in yasuni uh just eight months ago
um is true there even though there is no
road there
like the last um few hours of approach
um to to get there it's an all-day trip
um
is by river in fact you know you go you
go over the andes from quito to
to coca and you get on the rio napo for
for a while
and then uh you get on a dirt road um in
a truck
um that was built by the oil companies
uh for a little bit
and then the road ends and you get back
on to now the rio de patini
uh both of which are you know
tippatini's a tributary of the napo and
opposed the tributary of the
i think it's directly to retire of the
amazon if i remember correctly
um but so there is no road where we are
where where we go and yet um
and yet it is happening there too it is
happening there too and it's happening
you know for one thing this is a field
station so there's lots of longitudinal
data about
various clades longitudinal meaning time
so we know that bird populations are
radically decreasing
we know that bat populations are
radically decreasing
um the one that i didn't see coming was
in between our
this most recent trip and the one before
cayman had been very common on the river
such that if you went you know even a
little ways on the river at night with a
headlamp you you would see cayman
we didn't see a single cayman no clue
how that's connected to anything else
why caiman populations
would have dropped it could they used to
line the banks in some in some places it
wasn't you had like the cayman areas and
the turtle areas and
and they were just always a lot and
turtles as well
um yeah there were many fewer turtles so
you know what is it is it um that the
insect population has crashed
and that this indirectly came and don't
eat insects but they
do eat fish and many of those fish
survive on insects that have fallen into
the water or
things like this so who knows what the
connection is if you want to see the
reverse of this so basically
complex system however came and
connected to whatever is changing in
this
remote piece of habitat who knows the
reverse story is told
by the wolves that were reintroduced to
yellowstone
and there's beautiful work showing this
radical cascade of
effects where the reintroduction of the
wolves adjusts the um
the deer population right the deer are
no longer free
to forage wherever they want which
creates an increase in the diversity of
plants anyway you get this cascading
beautiful effect from the reintroduction
of this you know top carnivore
um so anyway it's all complex systems
and basically
stop messing with them and magic happens
and you start messing with them and
you can't keep up with the symptoms it's
like it's like a body that you're
you know you're giving them a
pharmaceutical for something and then
you're treating the
side effects and the side effects and
eventually that's right the whole system
falls apart
yeah so um
[Music]
you and i both grew up in la and
experienced fires there
and in fact we've we also saw um i was
just thinking
about what are our other experiences
with fires um
certainly in the last two decades the
american west has been experiencing
worse and more frequent fires i remember
actually on our honeymoon
in turkey driving west from cappadocia
coming across a wildland fire that
appeared to have been intentionally set
and it was on bo
it was it was in a grassland that was
low and it was on both sides of the road
and it seemed
safe enough we weren't this stupid it
seemed safe enough that we stopped
the car that we had rented and took
pictures of it
and sort of stood there watching this
meandering line beautiful fire
move across this landscape it was near
sunset as well so the colors were
extraordinary it felt less apocalyptic
than what's going on outside our windows
right now
um and i don't you know we never talked
to anyone about there was no one around
to talk to about it
um but it it certainly i think and i'm
not sure even we talked about it but i
think
immediately we both viewed this as this
looks to
this looks like no one's worried about
it this looks intentional this looks
like management and there was nothing it
was going to reach there weren't
structures or a forest that it was going
to get loose in it would be grassland
burning and you know grasslands after
fires
our new growth is prompted and so for
people for
um pastoralists who have um animals that
graze
intentional setting of fires does
release does does prompt new growth of
grass and so your animals get more food
and it might you know
in fact there's um potentially regular
burning acro
in many many places in the world
basically in the fall to fatten up your
to to prompt new growth of grass to
fatten up your animals so that they can
make it through the long winter
so what though um
if if climate change um explains
something significant but probably less
than half
of the increase in in fires
uh in the american west we also have
this suppressive fire management
practice
uh which has not allowed which has been
homogeneous
at best and simply suppressive at worst
um we have drought um
that to some degree is just going to
happen so there's there's
there's natural cycles of of drought and
it may just be our
time right uh and what else
we have sprawl which is putting people
in direct
contact with lands that might otherwise
uh burn and you know burn themselves out
with some regularity
we care more about every single fire um
we've got
i hesitate to even say it but we've got
um
people who have lost the plot and
are no longer in on the agreement
that once um we all held that it was bad
when um things
burned right when you know that's not to
say that every fire is bad but
there are people who are setting
destructive fires
um with their own purposes whether it's
to make the news
or uh something else but
the fact is that's right um fire
is a force multiplier
right so terrorists trade
in fear an organization of a certain
size can create a much bigger effect if
they can scare you into hurting yourself
fire is not exactly that it's not about
fear it's actually destructive but the
point is
one idiot can do an
awful lot of damage they can control an
awful lot of
resource by
triggering these things and the problem
is
there's really not a whole lot we can do
to stop it you wouldn't want to live in
the dystopia
in which everything was so well
monitored but you know
yeah so you you called them people who
have lost the plot
what i've written here is intentional
provocateurs
as opposed to sort of human landscape
modelers who are trying to do some kind
of good
so from that original that call figure
that i that i showed it's
um be they people who have lost the plot
and are individual bad actors or people
who have lost the plot and think that
fire
is a reasonable form of modern protest
arson is actually not a legitimate
thing to be engaging in now and there
has been
you know as as the fires have um have
become worse and worse over the last
several weeks
there has been uh increasingly as you
would expect
you know the mainstream media is now
saying anyone who talks about arson
as a cause of any of these fires is
clearly um
you know on the right and um doesn't
have their their finger on the pulse of
reality
and you know i would say once again um
the idea that with so much data still
out with so much of the story still
unknown the idea that it is impossible
that any of these fires were set by
arson
um and therefore if you say that any of
them were or might have been set by
arson
you are making a political point is
itself a political point and therefore
we don't have to listen to you well and
it's just
actually at this point we know for sure
that some of them are set by us and we
don't know
what the political leanings of those
people were or we can imagine at all
whether it was a mat or
it was political at all but we there was
good strong evidence at this point
that some not most but some of these
fires
were set by humans um with um
with purposes that were not in anyone's
best interests
yeah and it you know the fact is we've
had tons of arson
here in portland in the last 100 some
odd days
yeah right now it hasn't been wildfires
but
um it is perfectly it is a perfectly
legitimate question
we have ample evidence that there has
been arson involved some of the fires
that were started by arson were then put
out by citizens
immediately so you know what the nature
of any of this was we don't know but
um but nonetheless we have to look
ourselves in the eye and say a couple
things
one you cannot play this stupid game
where you tell certain people that
whatever they do in the name of some
cause that we agree in the abstract is a
good one
is legitimate right you cannot set a
fire
against racism a that doesn't make any
freaking sense
and b um it's going to become an excuse
for everybody who's looking i mean
what's really happened is we've got it's
the same era though as racism is a
pandemic
it's the same error it's using the
metaphor it's using the thing that is
actually going on in the physical world
and applying that as a metaphor
to the current social justice issue and
sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't but it's never literal
yeah it's never literal you can't what
did you mean that phrase was amazing
what did you just say you can't set a
fire
against racism it wasn't quite what you
said no
it was close something like that and you
know and no systemic racism is not a
pandemic
and you can't set a fire against racism
and that doesn't mean
that we're saying racism isn't real but
you know yeah you guys have seriously
lost the plot if that's what you think
is the right way to deal with this well
or the rest of us have freaking lost the
plot because what we actually have
is long standing tiny
or anarchist fringe that has of late
glommed on to a nominally anti-racist
movement right and the point is what's
actually driving this
anarchism and what does it look like
anarchism
right right go figure you know they've
been telling us that they
they wanted anarchy and they've told us
why and it doesn't add up but the point
is
we now have municipal authorities making
excuses for these people
that is going to increase their
likelihood of
committing all kinds of crimes because
they've effectively been told i mean you
know all of the people who've been
uh released after committing crimes and
being arrested for them and all of the
you know the tools that was collected to
get them released
right um you know we had ted wheeler
announcing this week that he's no longer
uh gonna allow the use of tear gas to
dispel these riots
yeah he snuck that in right as the fires
were getting real close to portland uh
kind of like an eleventh hour
uh thing that no one was going to notice
yep yeah
it's preposterous so i don't know are we
uh where you wanted to go
firewise yeah there's a there's a lot
more to do but i think i think we're
probably good for uh for one thing we
still need to talk about sex
oh right let's talk about sex
i won't say it should i say it no i
won't say so we watched
uh cuties last night um
the netflix uh i guess it wasn't created
by netflix
um the
hour and a half long narrative film
describing a a
group of 11 year old girls in paris i
guess it is
who are dancing
i'm going to put that in quotes um two
and we follow amy in particular who is
the daughter of
are they senegalese senegalese
immigrants um and she is not feeling
at home in her home for a lot of good
reasons
in part because uh her mother
is disempowered in life as an observant
muslim
and her father has gone back to senegal
to pick up a second wife
and this feels to amy we are led to
believe quite horrifying and
disempowering
as it would be as and in that part of
this film
uh i you know i i got it made it made a
lot of sense of course that would be
awful and there's a scene early on in
which she ends up
under a bed because she was doing
something she didn't want her mom and
auntie
um to see and so when they come in she
just hides she doesn't mean to be
eavesdropping but she's eavesdropping on
the conversation
which i think is the auntie is telling
the mom you need to call all the family
members and tell them how pleased you
are
about your husband's new wife and how
you hope that they'll be very fertile
and uh after the auntie leaves the mom
breaks down and is crying and it's
it's clearly an awful situation and um
you know situations in which polygeny is
forced on women are
exactly not empowering uh and uh
and that's awful however
however uh the idea that this
hyper-sexualized pre-teen
dance again in quotes behavior by by
girls
is an antidote uh is
we are led to believe now maybe part of
the point they were trying to make in
the film
but but no there is so much graphic
sexualization of these little girls in
this film
uh that uh that could have been done
differently without actually bringing
bringing all of our attention to their
budding sexual bodies
and the fact is that the opposite of
female disempowerment
is not female female hypersexualization
it's not
both of these things both of these ways
of being are deeply disempowering of
women
so um i'm not sure that wasn't the point
of
the screenplay
i i found the wit the that um pointing
out that this
preteen twerking uh
is so spell out what you mean what
you're not sure that what wasn't the
point
years ago uh i was at one of these
idw events in sydney australia
and i made a point that uh eric then
quickly jumped in and he said nobody was
going to get it but that it was a next
level point and the point i tried to
make
was that the um
obvious problem with uh
[Music]
way muslim culture at least in orthodox
sections deals with women is something
that the west is not in a good position
to comment on because as much as
you know a burka is a troubling
um thing to inflict on women the west
has created an entirely different
problem and it is this
hypersexualization
of girls um and so i thought
actually i i detested this film okay
it was both um tedious
and disgusting at the same time right
um to the extent that it you know
like the moment-to-moment plot was like
a you know it was like lord of the
butterflies like a girl version of lord
of the flies
you know actually and that that's that's
important
i don't want to interrupt for long but
we also saw this group of four girls
sometimes five but sort of oscillating
group of four girls
behaving like a gang of errant boys
except that they were using their
budding sexuality to get what they
needed
but they were being aggressive and uh
and you know they were act they were
they were play acting as boys and as
women and in fact they're neither
they're girls
right so anyway the film
wasn't any good but the very final scene
suggested to me that it was not making
the point that i
thought it was making which was that
this
hypersexualization is the antidote to
the other thing the
very final scene seems to suggest that
it was making a point more like the one
that i was trying to make in australia
which is that both of these answers are
absurd
and that that's a problem right that
basically these are girls and they
should be allowed to be girls rather
than be
turned into to women early and yet the
very final scene is like
15 seconds it's 15 seconds long more
than an hour and a half
i was surprised to see it because i was
already writing my scathing review in in
my head and then it was like oh
actually maybe they do have the right
point now the film is still despicable
right it's still despicable because it
was actually filmed with
underage girls which meant that it
couldn't avoid
doing the very thing that maybe it was
critiquing
right and somebody made some decisions
in the making of this film
to sexualize these girls in a way that
would probably increase audience because
it will
appeal to a certain fraction of
presumably straight
men which is despicable so the point
that tulsi gabbard made on twitter
yesterday that had her trending
about the fact that this is likely to
increase things like trafficking
is surely right and then there's the
ultimate uh
evil here which is what netflix has done
with it
right so the point is netflix clearly in
the way that they
are attempting to attract people is not
in possession of
what this actually was which is a
very questionable art film right right
what netflix decided to do was turn it
into a sensation
either because of the sexualizing of
young girls or because of the
controversy that would arise out of
doing that
either way my god right we're actually
going to tolerate
netflix doing this but
the whole thing is sort of tangled
because
i you know i don't know whether i don't
know what was on the mind of the
the screenwriters if it had been
um a book in which there were no
actresses
and it made the same point that i think
it was making in that very final scene
then i would say
yeah that's an important point right by
doing it in this way
that um for the entirety of the film
seems to be suggesting that you know
this is liberation
um totally pollutes that message and
then for it to be co-opted by
a an economic goliath with its own
bottom line in mind
um is is truly troubling yeah it is
and it's not i don't think there's any
excuse for any of the
um explicit visual sexualization of of
the children
in the film um but it's not even just
one scene it's throughout
it you know it starts early and it goes
to the penultimate scene basically
and uh it is it's excruciating
and uh it's at some level more of the
same
uh that uh that you know hollywood
and madison avenue etc have been giving
us for
decades and decades and decades except
the
age range about which it's acceptable is
advancing earlier and earlier and like
if what what kind of a country imagines
that sexualizing children is okay i i
can't even
imagine what's in your head if you think
that that's okay like you have
again you know really lost the plot on
what childhood
is and should be and can be
and must be i totally agree with this
and i as i was watching
um this film um
i did have the following odd thought
which was suppose there had been no
controversy
right suppose that somehow we had
encountered this thing and thought okay
french art film
you know senegalese immigrants and
watched it without any
um without any uh context expectations
of what it was i am sure that i would
have found it despicable
but i am not sure that i would have
found it noteworthy
in other words this is part and parcel
of what we do to girls and the thing
that was extreme here was
how young the girls were but the fact
that we are
constantly being bombarded with messages
that um hyper-sexualized girls that play
games with actresses who may be you know
adults but are playing younger right
this whole thing is just how the west
functions and it's
to me i think it's almost entirely the
result of madison avenue
using female sexuality this very potent
force to sell [ __ ]
right and that in that the fact that it
has affected the way women view
themselves as almost a byproduct
of the desire to raise people's
insecurities in order to get them to buy
things
but i i don't think i would have
thought maybe i would have thought to
tweet my god did i see a terrible film
let me tell you what's in it but i'm not
sure that
it would have you know would have stood
out i i
bet there's a good chance we wouldn't
have finished watching it oh absent the
context right it would just sort of
start and i'm like what are they doing
wow no never mind right just just just
not watching this
um i guess i want to just reiterate what
i think i said earlier but maybe didn't
say clearly which is that
this is this is being sold to us
as a response to the disempowerment and
desexualization
of the women in this senegalese
immigrant
muslim uh community and
there is then this conflation of sex
with power and this you know this is
very much in the you know critical
theories um
genre of thinking through post-modernism
and post-structuralism and such
um sex obviously is used as power as we
were just talking about by madison
avenue by young women bought you know
in a lot and a lot of places but the
idea that
observing that a
family structure community structure
routinely and frankly systemically
disempowers women
and that probably that
disempowering of women is about
controlling of sex
does not mean that the response to that
ought to be
all sex all the time as early as
possible um
absent any any community interaction
or commitment or anything because that
is also not going to empower anyone
you are not you are you are not going to
simply
have power if you flaunt sexuality at
every at every turn
um just because you have observed
correctly um that women in your
community
um are decentralized and also have no
power
yeah two things uh one of these points i
think is
is going to be very hard to make but
the control that society
almost inevitably exerts over female
sexuality
is not about controlling females per se
it's about society right and so this is
the
point i tried to make in australia is
that in fact there is a problem
when human beings are living in high
density
which has to do with the effect that
sexuality um
the disruptive effect that it has if
there's not some
mechanism that keep some kind of order
and the point i made in australia was
there are many different mechanisms some
of them
are laughable some of them are
ghastly all of them the unfairness of
all of them falls too heavily on women
right but
it is society figuring out mechanisms to
address an actual structural problem
that um that results in
in this and so you know
at some level the upshot is we don't
have a good solution here we've got lots
of bad solutions
but this is the inevitable result
you know of society in which um
you know it is perfectly natural for uh
cardi b to be talking to joe biden in
the midst of a presidential election
as if we you know why are we shocked
as if that's also getting this
indicating that he thinks women should
be empowered
as opposed to actually if there's any
message there
it's applauding hypersexualization and
the cheapening of sex
of women by women and this is another
difficult point to make but the point is
actually you know what
female sexual power is power
but females are in competition with
themselves in a sense because
which power do you want to drive the
world do you want
female achievement to be the kind of
female power that women should aspire to
or do you want their ability
to tangle society in knots which of
course
fades so no and i think this is um this
is in fact the key tension between sort
of second wave feminism and
later waves feminism that second wave
feminism was
aspiring to free women from many of the
domestic shackles that you know some of
which
are simply biologically enforced by
anatomy and physiology by the fact that
women are who
gestate and lactate but
freeing women from the from the inherent
expectation that you know you will have
you will be married and have children
early and you will be the ones
you will be the one staying home and
taking care of them it's sort of a solo
parenting role which itself is a novel
thing right you know
in monogamy that tends to be by parental
care
um not the sort of 1950s housewife
version of
of family life which is a very weird
little blip that i don't know why anyone
aspires to that
but so second wave feminism was about
freeing women from constraints that we
could be freed from
and presumably allowing us to make
decisions
based on what it was that we wanted to
do in the world
achievement and you know observing
that men and women are different and
that women will sometimes make the same
choices as men and sometimes different
ones and those choices may actually
help society become a better place as
well and let's actually
embrace the kinds of contributions that
women can make in the world
that all feels to me like the kind of
second wave feminism that my
mother and her business partner and the
women who i had as role models when i
was growing up
engaged with and then we have this third
way feminism come around
which is about using the power that you
have as your sexuality
to trick men into doing stuff and to
you know pretend that that means that
you're in power and you're not it's not
powerful
a it's it will end you know actual
achievement
will grow over time just like male
actual achievement grows over time
why would you pick the model of power
that is brief
that is fleeting uh and that is actually
disempowering
well because you suddenly come into it
when you're
15 16 17 11 apparently if you're in
cuties
and um it's it's surprising it's
shocking
and uh you know every young woman has to
figure out how to
how to deal with it but imagine that
that's the pinnacle of your life it's
like being the dude on the football team
at 17
who's that's his best moment in life
that's that is the equivalent
of um aspiring to be you know only a
sexual being and that that is what your
value is as a woman
and it's you know it has always struck
me as anti-feminist
faux feminist and of course it goes by
third wave feminism and doesn't seem
like
anything anything empowering of women
yeah it's it's an inversion of feminism
the thing that i would add is that
it is also largely arbitrary you know
like melanin content of your skin right
why do we want people judged by the
content of their character rather than
the color of their skin
because it makes for a better world
right if if we do that and so the point
is it's an immutable characteristic is
what you're saying
it may i don't want to say it's totally
immutable it may be that you know
a beautiful woman is in part beautiful
because or a beautiful young woman is
beautiful because
you know she uh puts effort into
being fit or whatever but um but it is
largely
immutable and so there the question is
really
you know we could take a traditional
view and you know women are sort of
playing the supportive role
at home many of us don't want that right
we don't want that but we also don't
want a anything that empowers women is
good
because of what's empowering you is that
you're waving your tits in somebody's
face
that's not it doesn't produce it's not
productive right i don't want that any
more than anything that empowers men is
good
anything that empowers pick your
demographic
is good is a terrible rubric and will be
gamed and we see that in black lives
matter
we see that in me too we see that in
cuties we see it across the board of
course we do
right and so what you want is a system
in which
um the women who are empowered to speak
for example to presidential candidates
and things like that
are women who have accomplished
something that has
brought you know that's made the world
more interesting
uh has extended our capacity in some way
right has contributed right the
mythology of markets
is that you get paid for contributing to
our welfare by creating things
that enhance us and the problem is if we
put too much emphasis
on uh youthful sexuality in females
which you know there's a biological bias
in favor of exactly that
then what the point is the females who
end up empowered
are inherently going to be young and
that means
the chances that they will actually know
something worth conveying
are that much lower right youth and
wisdom are inversely correlated almost
always
right and you can be wise beyond your
years but you you know you can't be wise
as a very young person
yeah and so anyway it's really you know
these two kinds of feminism are in
competition with each other and when you
spot
the direction one of them pulls it is
absolutely anti-feminist
yep that's right so
you wanted to say some things about
unity before we uh before we stopped i
think
um yeah just a little bit of an update
we are uh
you know at a kind of an interesting
moment with unity twitter has of course
said nothing yet about why it is that
it's suspended our account it has
ignored the appeal that we've
filed and it's just now gone silent and
um increasingly i think the only
explanation for this behavior
is political we found no evidence of the
things that we were rumored to have
engaged in
uh when eric talked to jack uh and
you know the things that were spread
online we are not russian bots we did
not register large numbers of accounts
in order to
trend a hashtag um so anyway
at some level i think we are discovering
um
that you know twitter is not the ghost
in the machine
the ghost is the machine it has its
thumb on the scales
it is adjusting the way democracy works
it is deciding
what a legitimate political perspective
is and what it isn't and it favors the
duopoly which is not surprising
because of course it has
disproportionate influence over how we
are to be governed through that duopoly
so what the hell are we going to do i
mean this is this is this is
um an impossibly dangerous force and
what i fear is that it is going to
prevent any kind of
change that is not seen by the duopoly
as in its interest
and that that change has become
increasingly essential and on a short
time scale
so that is uh roughly where we find
ourselves
we are still forging ahead i am hopeful
um we have begun to interact with
joe jorgensen i'm hoping she will come
on our campfire and talk to us about the
possible partnership between
libertarians
and the unity movement she is skeptical
but
um i believe when she sees uh
what our perspective really is that she
might well um
be willing to partner
all right oh so zach is giving us our
signal that we are
we are finishing up um okay so we'll
take a 15-minute break
as we do and answer your superjet
questions from this hour
first as many as we can and then um pick
up answering your super chat questions
from
the q a hour in the order in which they
come in
we do appreciate your support in that
regard
you can join either of us on our
patreons
to get access to the private discord
server um and
me on mine uh to get access to our once
a month private q a
that i will be soliciting questions for
in about a week
and what else maybe that's about it
maybe that's about it
so we will um uh we'll be back in about
15 minutes
all right we'll see you in 15. be well
[Music]
[Music]
you